variables a variable is a container for
a value the value can be many things
such as a number or a string like part
of a sentence or give me an object or a
complex function with variables the
value in the container can change to use
a variable you first have to declare it
there that variable has now been created
or or declared you're going to create a
variable using the VAR keyword the Const
keyword or the let keyword now before
es6 you could just use var so that's
still the most common but those other
keywords are available after creating
the variable you must initialize the
variable this is where you just give it
a value this is done with the equal sign
there we just initialize my name
variable with the name Bo it's a string
you can also declare and initialize a
variable all at once so we declared the
variable state and we initialized it as
Michigan you can use variables all over
the place in JavaScript so here if you
want to console that log is just going
to put something into the console over
here
so I put my name is use a string here
and then I'm going to add a variable
that's also a string and we're going to
run that so we can see it right in the
console it's going to do my name is Bo
see there's no space within isn't Bo
because you have to put a space here now
once a variable has had a value assigned
to it you can update that value by just
simply giving it a different value so
I'm going to put state equals California
so before state equaled Michigan and now
stay equals California so if we cancel
that law get or do anything like that
it's going to equal Tala for Nia there
are certain naming rules and conventions
for variables generally you should just
stick to using Latin characters like 0
through 9 or a to Z or even capital A to
Z and you should not use underscores at
the start of variable names while this
is allowed it has certain meanings and
could get confusing so don't use to
underscore at the start numbers at the
start of the variable will cause an
error so you can't have a variable that
starts with the number it can have a
number in it just not at the beginning a
safe convention to stick to is the lower
camelcase
so this is just a naming convention so
it says my name up here let's lower
camel keys when you stick multiple words
together you should do it without a
space and you should capitalize every
word after the first word so if we're
gonna have a longer variable so that's
lower camel case there's no space with
capitalize each word just like the name
of free code camp is in lower camel case
you should always make variable names
intuitive so they describe the data they
contain also this is very important
variables are case sensitive so a
capital letter and a lowercase letter
are completely different lastly you
should not use JavaScript reserved words
as your variable names this means words
that make up the actual syntax of
JavaScript such as var function if-else
for and one final thing about variables
javascript is a loosely typed language
which means that unlike some other
languages you don't need to specify what
data type a variable will contain such
as number or string or object or
anything like that
javascript just figures it out for you
well that's variables thanks for
watching my name is Bo Carnes don't
forget to subscribe and remember use
your code for good